really upset not to win it was a case
that could have changed abortion law as
we know it a case that for many is
highly personal
heidi's husband james was at her side as
the judgment was read out she's the
first to sue the government for allowing
unborn babies with disabilities to be
aborted until birth all i want is for
people to accept us
that's all i want
we are amazing just the way we are
let me just see the person behind it as
a chromosome
and that's what i did when i met james
that doesn't define us
she is
an amazing woman
and i'll be holding her hand
and said it's going to be okay
the case was also bought by moyer whose
son aidan is two so i've got two sons
and i you know i absolutely love them
both and i value them equally and i just
i really feel like the law should as
well it's been really hard work it's
quite emotional and it's been quite
draining at times but
i just so strongly believe that you know
aidan deserves to be treated equally and
seen equally and i would hate for him to
grow up and become aware of this law and
feel hurt by it so yeah i will
i will keep fighting for him
there are strong feelings on both sides
of this and the judges today said that
this was a highly sensitive case but
that the law as it stands protects the
rights of women in difficult
circumstances
this was actually about removing women's
access to abortion after 24 weeks
for any abortion deemed to be a
non-fatal condition now that's actually
incredibly complex it's really important
that for a small number of women who
find that there are
issues diagnosed sometimes later in
pregnancy that they have the time and
space to make the choice that is right
for them
heidi will now try to appeal a case that
balances a woman's right to choose an
equality for people with disabilities
i'm the winner in his eyes
ali ford's sky news